it is now one month since Anheuser-Busch
decided to destroy its best-selling beer
the best-selling beer in America by
sponsoring a particularly offensive
transvestite in putting his picture on
the beer can within a week sales dollars
were down six percent
volume was down 11 percent
but the company thought they could
weather the storm by doubling down and
refusing to apologize that turned out to
be a bad strategy since the numbers
continued to fall the following week
sales were down 17 percent in dollars
and a shocking 21 percent in volume that
was for the week ending April 15th that
was when Bud Light decided to reverse
course kind of by blaming a lower level
executive and claiming ignorance at the
top and sort of kind of but ultimately
not really apologizing they released a
commercial about horses or something
that didn't work either and now
according to figures reported by Barons
and bump Williams Consulting sales
volume is down more than 26 percent for
the week ending April 22nd
it would have been bad for
Anheuser-Busch if they had suffered a
one-week drop in sales over Dylan
Mulvaney would have been worse if they'd
taken a hit and sales didn't get better
but this is the worst outcome of all for
Bud Light they took a massive hit and
sales have just kept on collapsing with
no end in sight so what are the Geniuses
over at Bud Light doing now
they've released another offense
straddling commercial that says nothing
insurance
[Music]
properly diverse proud
all kind of ethnically ambiguous
they're in a fun field
fry starting to rain
[Music]
just a bunch of people walking around in
the rain easy to drink easy to enjoy
Bud Light used to be easy to drink now
not so much hey conservatives
you guys like blue jeans and that
Chicken Fried song right yeah yeah
show them that do that maybe put one of
the girls in a cowboy hat or boots or
something yeah those Hicks will eat that
up they'll forget about how much we
support transgenderism those roofs
they'll buy anything easy to drink no we
won't we won't and we definitely won't
be buying Bud Light
Anheuser-Busch is pursuing a strategy
that many a squishy Republican has tried
to follow in our increasingly liberal
culture Anheuser-Busch wants to stand in
the middle of the road they think the
biggest risk to their reputation is to
pick a side
after all picking a side with Mulvaney
hurt them
and maybe if they'd shut up for even
three or four days maybe they could have
weathered the boycott better but the
fact is
they did take a side on a major
political issue for which everyone
ultimately has to take a side do women
really exist as a real natural category
of people
or do they not
Bud Light chose the opposite side from
the one their customers are on now
they're paying the price they could fix
it by apologizing just apologize
just say that you oppose transgenderism
and that you support reality that would
earn them lots of sales dollars from
their customers from beer drinkers but
it would cost them lots of social points
with the liberal establishment that runs
our political order and that's a price
they're not willing to pay so Bud Light
Is straddling the fence dressing and
cross-dressing in blue jeans and skirts
lukewarm on a fundamental issue neither
hot nor cold as conservative spew Bud
Light out of their mouths
let it be a lesson to us all I'm Michael
Knowles this the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show there's a
beautiful clip from 60 Minutes going
around I don't think 60 Minutes intended
for the clip to have this effect but it
shows you the cynical reality of the
climate change movement
and all the fear about the end of the
world it totally exposes that movement
we'll get to that in one moment first
though
it's not just Bud Light
it's Disney this is a story from last
week I'm thrilled that I get to report
it this week I don't want to let this
one slip through the cracks Disney has
cut 15 of entertainment staffers
15 percent
why is that
well it's from a report in Bloomberg
it's at Disney CEO Bob Iger announced a
couple of months ago that Disney was
going to have to lay some people off as
part of a strategic realignment to
reduce costs why do they have to reduce
costs because the company's stock price
has declined 17 over the past year
and Disney viewers they're not they're
not the same customers as the Bud Light
customers
apparently there's some substantial
overlap
but you think of Bud Light you think
Frat Boys construction workers normal
people of course
going trans was going to affect their
sales numbers but Disney
the the adults that I know who like
Disney are pretty lib
and Disney's mostly made for kids but
kids have parents and maybe the parents
don't like the idea of Disney shoving
transgenderism down their throat in any
case 17 down not good numbers for them
how did Disney find themselves in this
mess well because the people of Florida
passed a simple bill that said hey
teachers bureaucrats apparatchics of the
liberal State we don't want you to trans
our kids so you don't get to trans our
kids anymore they pass that through
their representatives Disney said
hell yes we're going to trans your kids
it's the obedo or a rook line hill yes
oh yes we're going to take your guns and
trans your kids
and the parents don't like that and so
the parents are not giving Disney their
dollars anymore
they're they're giving their dollars to
other places they're giving their
dollars to people who are making kids
content that is free from all this woke
craziness people like Jeremy and the
daily wire over here
and it shows you a lesson that the
people are largely on our side
yes people who buy the regular old
conservative products
even the Disney people are on our side
the vast majority of Americans know that
transgenderism is fake it's not real
according to Pew research
sixty percent of Americans think that
your gender
just comes from your biological sex and
that's all there is to it I wish that
number were higher
but the number is moving in the right
direction because two years ago that
number was only 56 percent and six years
ago that number was only 54 so a clear
majority of Americans think this the
numbers are moving in the right
direction and if we just keep that
pressure up as we are doing successfully
against some of the biggest companies in
the country against the best-selling
beer in the country the corporations are
going to get that message and either
they'll Shape Up
or what's more likely because even
though they want to sell their product
they don't want to
irritate the liberal establishment that
runs our political order
the alternative is you're going to get
an alternative economy
like you're seeing here at DW and like
you're seeing other people do as well
now when you want to decide which
companies you work for buy from work
with in our economy
you got to check out ZipRecruiter right
now go to ziprecruiter.com Knowles when
you want to hire the best people you've
got to check out ziprecruiter.com
Knowles kwlas hiring used to be really
hard you'd post your job on multiple
sites you'd hope the right people would
see it then you would wait for them to
apply the same goes for finding a job
you'd upload your resume to every job
posting site and comb through
never-ending lists of jobs trying to
find the right position for you zip
recruiter is the best place to find the
right position or if you're an employer
the right person to join your team head
on over right now to ziprecruiter.com
try it for free sip recruiters matching
technology excels at finding the most
qualified candidates for a wide range of
roles if you see a candidate that you
like you can easily send them a personal
invite so they're more likely to apply
it also gives you Competitive Edge
against other employers who may also be
interested in that candidate their
user-friendly dashboard makes it easy to
filter review and rate your candidates
all from one plays four out of five
employers who post on ZipRecruiter get a
quality candidate within the first day
see it for yourself ziprecruiter.com
Knowles try it for free ziprecruiter.com
ZipRecruiter the smartest way
to hire
some Democrats
realize the party has gone too far
they're trying to bring the Democrats
back from the brink this includes a
presidential candidate don't forget Joe
Biden doesn't just have the nomination
for re-election in 2024. Joe Biden's
gonna have to run to primary he's got
one opponent named Marianne Williamson
who's kind of a
kooky new AG crystals lady and then he's
got another opponent who is a Kennedy
who is from a very established Democrat
family who's had a long career as an
environmental lawyer pursuing all sorts
of liberal causes but he's a little
heterodox when it comes to the Democrats
he's heterodox on big Pharma and
vaccines and he's heterodox on the
transgender issue at least to some
degree Bobby Kennedy Jr running as a
Democrat was just asked what he thinks
about men competing against women in
women's sports
here's his answer as a Democrat
thanks
I I'm against people participating in
women's sports
um who have who are you know who are
biologically male
I think women have worked too hard to
develop a sporting you know to develop
women's sports over the past 30 years I
watched it happen and I don't think
that's fair
of course totally right
the vast majority of Americans agree
with RFK Jr on this
but this is not great for Bobby Kennedy
Jr
because
his campaign pitch is basically that he
is a Democrat from the 1960s
he's not a Republican
he's not a conservative he actually is a
liberal and he actually is a Democrat
but he's not a 2023 Democrat
he's he's a Democrat from the 60s who
says we're going to fight the power
we're going to fight the man we want to
defuse political power in the in the
country Democrats from 2023 say give all
your money to Big Pharma and allow big
Pharma to capture the FDA and to have it
be a revolving door so that the the
people who are supposed to be regulating
the corporations actually work for the
corporations and vice versa
Bobby Kennedy's made it one of his big
professional missions to stop that sort
of thing
that doesn't work with the Democrats in
Democrats in 1960s would say we want
women to have their own sports and we
want Title IX and we want Title VII and
we want to protect women as a special
class we're our feminists
Democrats in 2023 say what is a woman I
don't know what a woman is forget about
that no women don't have the right to
their own sports women don't have the
right to their own bathrooms women don't
have the right to their unemployment
protections actually when it says you
have a protection for sex in the civil
rights laws that actually means a
protection for gender identity which
totally undermines the predictions for
sex that's what a 2023 Democrat says
but they're both different from what the
conservatives say
they're both different from what a
Conservative Republican then or now says
and Bobby Kennedy is going to lose his
fight I wish him luck I hope he really
weakens the Democratic party I hope he
raises uncomfortable conversations for
them but
it's not going to work for him and the
reason it's not going to work is not
only that his party is very corrupt and
is able to keep out Outsiders in these
nominating contests but it's also
because
ideas have a power of Their Own
and ideas will be followed to their
logical conclusions you can't just
freeze them that's why when people on
either side of the aisle say I want to
go back to 1950 or I want to go back to
1970 or I want to go back to this age or
that you can't go back you can never go
back
in time we live in the present and this
world that we're in has been formed by
the ideas that have predated it
so if you if you rewind the clock
somehow 30 40 years you're very likely
to end up in the same place you are now
because the ideas have momentum they
have a direction of Their Own
Bobby Kennedy says I've I want to
protect women's sports because
I think what he's implying is because we
had the feminist movement that won all
these important rights and protections
for women okay but the feminist movement
was predicated on the idea that men and
women are basically the same
so men and women should not have
distinct roles in society and private
and public life because
a woman needs a man like a fish needs a
bicycle because there are some cosmetic
differences but women and men are pretty
much exactly the same okay well if women
and men are pretty much exactly the same
then you're going to get the sexual
Revolution and you're going to get the
gay rights movement and you're going to
get the redefinition of marriage and
you're going to get transgenderism and
you're going to get translating the kids
because that is the logical progression
of those ideas
and when the ideas come to their logical
conclusions
and we see how absurd those conclusions
are then we can more clearly look back
at the origin of those ideas and say huh
looks like they started from pretty
mistaken premises doesn't it
and that that that's much clearer when
those ideas have played out but what
you're not going to do is say okay well
let's just rewind the clock 20 30 years
that's that's not going to make any
sense that's not going to persuade
anybody where is the Democrat Party on
this issue now they're they're full
steam ahead they are so far past Bobby
Kennedy it is not even funny it really
is not funny
because what did we say what did all the
conservatives say
we said years ago
well if you get the sexual Revolution
stuff pretty soon they're going to
redefine marriage oh no that's a
slippery slope argument that's crazy
that's not going to happen but of course
they redefine marriage so well if you
redefine marriage then pretty soon
you're going to have all of these even
more eccentric disorder kind of family
structures like polyamorous
relationships and thruples and oh
Michael that's crazy what are you
talking about and then of course that's
what we get and then what happened the
final frontier was
pretty soon
these guys are going to try to establish
legal protections
for pedophilia they're going to try to
normalize pedophilia oh how dare you
suggest that that's out bigoted that's
phobic how dare you say that well I
don't know I mean we're kind of seeing
it in Academia there are some prominent
academics now who have called for uh
getting rid of the term pedophile and
changing it to map minor retracted
person and they're arguing that
pedophilia is innate and therefore
because of the premises of this modern
sexual movement if something's innate if
a desire is comes from birth or in your
early years of formation then you can
never change it and you can never
suppress it it's wrong to repress your
desires and so you know we're we're
going to have to normalize this stuff
that's what we're hearing in Academia
and now it's what we're hearing
in politics that's what we're hearing in
government a Minnesota trans identifying
Democrat lawmaker I don't even really
have to say Democrat but
that's what this guy is
he just tried to alter a bill
to protect pedophilia as a sexual
orientation
here it is I've got the text of it right
here
Minister Minnesota statutes 2022 section
363 a03 subdivision 44 is amended to
read subdivision 44 sexual orientation
sexual orientation means having or being
perceived as having an emotional
physical or sexual attachment to another
person without regard to the sex of that
person or having or being perceived as
having an orientation for such
attachment
then it goes on or it used to go on and
said or having or being perceived as
having a self-image or identity not
traditionally associated with one's
biological maleness or femaleness sexual
orientation does not include a physical
or sexual attachment to children by an
adult that's what it read and then this
Minnesota lawmaker
tried to amend this
to cross that out
to cross out hey no we don't want that
bigoted line in there but a sexual
orientation does not include a physical
or sexual attachment to children by an
adult that's so bigoted that's a phobic
we've got to get rid of that line
I'm not making this up here it is it's
right here got the text right here
this Minnesota State Rep is
representative Lee Finke I don't know
what his real name is some that's Lee
lay l-e-i-g-h sounds like one of these
made up transgender names so I don't I
don't know but anyway he's a guy who
identifies as a woman he's a member of
the democratic farmer labor party first
self-identified transgender person in
the Minnesota Legislature
and introduce this amendment in the take
pride Act
so what would it have done it would have
protected pedophilia as a sexual
orientation
protected from discrimination by the law
now
once this made headlines a few days ago
all of a sudden the Minnesota
legislators even the ones who were
generally allied with this guy
said okay we gotta correct this so they
took a vote in the house they said okay
we're still opposed to pedophilia right
and it it passed by unanimous vote
so even representative Finke here
realized okay I gotta back off this pedo
stuff for now
that's good glad
glad they all backed off for now
this is the direction it's going in
glad they took decisive action Bud Light
could learn a lesson or two from them
you can't take this away
you can't hide the fact that this is the
direction they wanted to go in now
speaking of pedophilia Governor Ron
DeSantis it would appear to be soon to
be presidential candidate Ron DeSantis
has come out
and pushed for the death penalty for
pedophiles in Florida
these are really the worst of the worst
and what happens is the perpetrators
these crimes are oftentimes serial
offenders and if someone does one if
they if they rape a child uh like and
these are very young very young children
sometimes like six seven eight years old
if they do that once chances are they
will do it again unless they're stopped
unless they're incapacitated and so we
really believe that part of a just
Society is to have appropriate
punishment and so if you commit a crime
that is um really really heinous you
should have the ultimate punishment and
so what this bill does is it challenges
the U.S Supreme Court for recently
deciding probably six or seven years ago
they decided by five to four after over
200 years of our of our constitution
being uh in in place that somehow you
could never have capital punishment
meant for crimes like rape
and so Ron DeSantis says we're
challenging that now if you rape a child
pretty much the most heinous crime you
can imagine you get the death penalty
totally agree with that in principle I
see no problem with that in principle I
see no problem with the death penalty in
principle in fact I think it's uh quite
natural biblical you see it defended by
some of the greatest Minds in the
history of the church and it not only
defended but even enacted by some of the
great popes in history so there's
nothing unchristian
about it there's nothing immoral about
it
and there's nothing unconstitutional
about it in the early days of our
country
the the definition of a felony was that
you would hang for it the death penalty
was widely applied much more widely than
it is today I don't actually agree with
this particular instantiation of the
death penalty in practice in principle I
do but in practice the only reason I
don't is that as a matter of prudence if
you don't
kill child rapists if the punishment is
not execution then it creates some
incentive for the rapist not to murder
his victim
so if there's any way that through the
law we can incentivize a rapist not to
murder his victim I think that's
probably wise and prudent
in principle they deserve death
certainly uh but putting all of that
aside for a second the difference
between the the law and principle and in
practice
the main thing about the story that's
interesting is
what governor DeSantis was standing in
front of he was not standing in front of
the flag of the State of Florida he was
not holding a regular press conference
with some signs behind him he was
standing in front of a big gigantic
American flag because he's obviously
about to announce his run for president
he is pushing for this
law that will obviously be almost
universally popular I guess not among
the pedo Defenders and and against and
and there are some people who are
thinking about this issue I think in a a
little more of a
wise as a serpent innocent is a dove
kind of way who are talking about the
actual practical effects but broadly
speaking execute pedos is a very popular
campaign slogan and so putting the the
meat of the law side for a second what
this is signaling is this guy is moving
full steam ahead and we can expect a
campaign announcement
soon
now what are you looking forward to in
your life are you looking forward to a
good education a change of pace maybe a
new Direction well you got to check out
Grand Canyon University are you ready to
take the next step in your education but
you're struggling to fit traditional
classes into your busy schedule Grand
Canyon University's online programs are
designed to make earning your degree
easy and accessible no matter your age
or stage in life I love Grand Canyon
University it's one of the first schools
that I ever visited when I started
speaking on campuses this was quite some
years ago now and oddly enough two of
those students who brought me to Grand
Canyon are now colleagues of mine at
different companies making a difference
clearly got a very good education
whether you're a busy professional
looking to advance your career or a
stay-at-home parent juggling family
responsibilities gcu's online courses
give you the flexibility you need to
learn on your own terms Grand Canyon
University specializes in helping you
fit your bachelor's Master's or doctoral
degree into your busy day from
scholarships to customized scheduling
your graduation team led by your own GCU
counselor provides you with the personal
support you need to succeed so why wait
if you're ready to take your education
to the next level you need Grand Canyon
University find your purpose at Grand
Canyon University gcu.edu that is
gcu.edu
are you looking for something
interesting to watch are you well check
out our series what we saw hosted by the
Storyteller Bill Whittle season one is
focused on Apollo 11 and now season two
is in full swing this time Bill paints a
bleak picture of a growing existential
threat to America due to Soviet Russia
and Cuba episode 8 picks up during 1961
during the aftermath of the disastrous
Bay of Pigs invasion in Cuba with the
Berlin Wall completed closing the Iron
Curtain on Western Europe the Soviets
have installed medium-range nuclear
weapons in Cuba one wrong move from
President Kennedy might set off an act
of War Bill makes you feel like you were
there witnessing history new episodes of
The Cold War come out every week but you
have to be a member to see it go to
dailywire.com Cold War to start watching
speaking of death
there's a terrible murder that just took
place
it was a Murder By an illegal alien
allegedly killed five people including a
an elementary school student a third
grade student
and
the Secretary of Homeland Security
can't answer a simple question about the
murderer
there is some question about a
citizenship he supposedly had a a I
guess they referred to it as a a
consulate card from Mexico meaning he
was here legally but perhaps he'd
overstayed so Chuck I I won't comment on
it because it is an active case the
tragedy that occurred is you described
it correctly just absolutely horrific
yeah of course it's horrific it's
horrific when five people are murdered
and especially when one of them is a
little child
why won't you comment on it the
government comments on all sorts of
tragic cases that was his excuse he says
I'm not going to comment on it it's a
tragic case
does the government doesn't comment on
terror attacks the government doesn't
comment on crime the government doesn't
comment on government sure commented a
lot on the January 6th Insurrection we
were told that was absolutely tragic
they don't stop commenting on that but a
murder that would appear to be
preventable
easily preventable you won't comment on
the question of whether or not the
murder was preventable
well I don't know I'm not going to
comment if he was an illegal alien or
not well I don't know the
the Immigration and Customs Enforcement
Agency has confirmed that the killer was
deported four times between 2009 and
2016. so look I'm no expert no
criminologist no immigration expert
would seem to me if a guy's deported
four times probably he's an illegal
alien wouldn't you say
oh we can't comment on that
why can't they comment
is if they say yes he was an illegal
alien that means that this
Administration has blood on its hands
because this Administration has welcomed
illegal aliens
they've encouraged illegal aliens to
cross the border the Democratic party
has done that it's not just Biden's
fault they've done that for decades now
because they think it gives them
intellectual advantage and in fact it
does
but one of the consequences of that is
you get gangsters from Latin America who
come in and murder people
and when that happens then
the federal government don't know
nothing Democrats that we can't comment
on that that's tragic
that's one reason the other explanation
I'm trying to be as charitable as I can
towards secretary mayorkas the other
explanation is that they just don't know
that's just as big an indictment of the
government as as if they did know and
encouraged the illegal Behavior you
don't know you got this guy
he's committed a terrible crime
you you've now you've got his
information and you can't tell you can't
even tell if the guy's a foreign
National or an American citizen we're
here legally
what an indictment of our immigration
system in any case it means that
practically speaking the U.S doesn't
have borders and why doesn't the U.S
have borders either because of the
incompetence of Democrats or because
of the malicious intent
and it would appear to me to be
the latter the White House is even worse
on this the White House was asked about
this easily preventable tragedy that
they have just chosen not to prevent
and here is Kareen jean-pierre's answer
on Friday evening a nine-year-old child
was murdered along with four others in
yet another shocking horrific Act of gun
violence in America this time in
Cleveland Texas
two of the women killed were discovered
on top of surviving children and appear
to be shielding them from gunfire
from the guns it's all it's the guns of
course it's always the guns
does anybody buy this I don't think
anybody buys this
I don't even think most Democrats buy
this
that it was the guns
a lot of people have guns in America
a lot of people have guns
the legal gun owners don't commit these
crimes
this guy
oropeza
he was not a legal gun owner
he did not have any right to have a gun
he didn't have any right to be in the
country he'd been deported number of
times he'd obviously committed a number
of crimes
he clearly obtained his gun through
illegal means
and so the White House solution to that
we've got to take guns away from
law-abiding Americans does anybody
believe that
this is like when the the Democrats
always try to blame the AR-15 they say
well what we need to do we need to ban
the AR-15 forget about handguns for a
second which are used in the vast
majority of gun related murders
no no we've got a we gotta forget about
even other rifles and shotguns we've
just got to get rid of the AR-15
why well because guns today are so much
more lethal than they used to be no
they're not
guns haven't actually changed all that
much in the last century and in many
ways the the common guns that people are
able to purchase in ordinary
circumstances are less lethal
back in the early 20th century
gangsters and mafiosi were using tommy
guns using fully automatic guns to
murder people now it's very very
difficult to obtain those guns
the AR-15 is much less lethal than a
Tommy Gun some kind of belt-fed fully
automatic machine gun
so it's not the guns
it's the criminals that you are
encouraging to enter our country but
it's amazing when you encourage violent
criminals whose first action in America
is to commit a crime
just by definition just by the way of
entering it's amazing that then when
that happens crime goes up isn't that
crazy who could have seen that one
coming
now speaking of
bad prosecutors
is a prosecutor in Florida State
Attorney one of these George Soros
funded attorneys
which is it's a really brilliant
political strategy by Soros in
particular other Democrats are filling
in as well other libs are filling in but
Soros has really pioneered this and he
has such influence as one of the as
probably the preeminent Democrat funder
in America Soros decided okay I'm not
going to focus on the big ticket races
I'm going to focus on these low-level
races where you don't need a lot of
money to get a prosecutor installed and
then what the prosecutor is going to do
is not prosecute the criminals and then
you're going to get Chaos on the streets
and you're going to get
an upending of society
so you got one of these people Monique
world
state attorney for Florida's ninth
Judicial District
she now is saying that Governor DeSantis
is going to remove her from office as
soon as this week
why
because
preventable deaths are occurring because
of what she is doing and what she is not
doing the Santas earlier this year
pointed out that Keith Moses 19 year old
was allowed onto the streets by this
prosecutor
then Moses is accused of shooting five
people murdering three people including
a nine-year-old Tiana major and a 38
year old and a 24 year old
this guy Moses had been arrested
multiple times for felonious crimes now
you might say well okay maybe he was
arrested before this state attorney
is placed into office
yeah he was but then he also came up he
was arrested when she was in office
he was arrested on a drug and gun charge
and she let him go
and then he went out allegedly and he
murdered three people including a
nine-year-old girl
and now DeSantis it would appear is
going to remove her from office
Liberals are crying about it and some of
the squishes I think are going to say
well no listen we have a process here
we have a process we can't just be using
our political power to remove the people
we don't like from office that's not
that's not very conservative of you is
it
um
why not
is this just
a fun little game that we're going to
play until conservatives inevitably lose
is politics just about
writing laments
elegies on the decline of Western
Civilization oh
how sad how wonderful things used to be
is it just about book reviews is it just
about angry tweets
is it just about all there we go again
[Music]
throwing our hands in the air and
sighing or
are we in politics to win and improve
things
which isn't
many people
in the conservative movement
feel much better about the former they
feel much more comfortable doing the
former sort of thing oh yes I'm going to
write an essay about
how this was all predictable
um yes I'm going to
write some cultural commentary on some
new hip-hop album or something like that
ah yes there we go but we're supposed to
lose
it was ever thus
many people feel comfortable with that
I'm not
wield the power wield it urgently
good stuff I hope DeSantis follows
through on this
it's it's the best move that he could do
for his presidential campaign
desantis's best bet right now is not to
out charm trump it won't happen his best
bet right now is not to even
differentiate himself on policy that
matters somewhat but they're pretty much
running in the same Lane the best bet
for DeSantis right now is to convince
people that he is able to wield power
effectively and say that I can build
power effectively and Trump can't do it
as effectively so vote for me
one great way to do that would be to
fire prosecutors like this lady
okay what about the Democrats side
what's going to happen is Bobby Kennedy
going to win
is Marianne Williamson going to win
what happens in the general Biden gets
the nomination is Biden going to win is
Trump going to win is DeSantis going to
get the nomination he's going to win
here's what a former opponent of Joe
Biden's
Bernie Sanders has to say about Biden's
chances
when we live in a nation where you have
a major political party the Republican
party where many not all but many of
their leadership doesn't even believe in
democracy they maintain the myth that
Trump won the last election they're
trying to keep people from voting
they're trying to deny women the right
to control their own bodies so that's a
whole issue out there if you believe in
democracy you want to see more people
vote not fewer people vote I think the
choice is pretty clear and that choice
is Biden and second of all what I do
believe is the Democrats and the
president have got to be stronger on
working-class issues they've got to make
it clear that we believe in a government
that represents all not just the few
take on the greed of the insurance
companies the drug companies Wall Street
all the big money interest and start
delivering for working-class people you
do that I think Biden is going to win in
a landslide
well it's kind of a big if wouldn't you
say now listen here I think I think it's
very clear that if Joe Biden completely
goes against everything that he's ever
fought for for his entire career if Joe
Biden completely flips his party's
platform on its head
and takes a party that is completely
beholden to all of the big corporate
interests and takes a party and a
platform that is completely doing the
bidding of the plutocrats of society and
just does totally the opposite of that
then he'll win in a landslide if my
grandmother had Wheels she would be a
wagon
if my aunt
had golions she would be my uncle that's
all that's all Biden has to do he just
has to be the opposite of Joe Biden okay
well
we'll we'll see if he can do it we'll
see if that even matters my favorite
comment yesterday is from Noah
who says when you don't know if you are
at the DNC or Satan Khan you are in the
year 2023. the thought occurred to me
and I'm not just saying it to throw
bombs or be hyperbolic in my rhetoric
what's the difference
between Satan Khan allegedly the largest
gathering of satanists in American
history that took place in Boston over
the weekend
and
the Democrat National Convention
what's really the difference
what what did Satan Khan
support Satan Khan had lectures on how
wonderful abortion is raise money for
abortion considered abortion to be a
sacred right Rite
the Democrats do exactly the same thing
the DNC will exalt abortion as the same
sort of sacred right
all right ght
both of them view it as both kind of
kinds of right
the Satan Khan talked about the
importance of
transgenderism in the transgender
identity elevated that to a sacred
matter for the satanists
Democrat National Convention exactly the
same thing
you might say well they look a little
different do they look different yeah at
Satan Khan they had all sorts of
pentagrams and Baphomet imagery and
Claws and creepy occult symbolism
the same can be said of Biden's White
House
you remember the guy the deputy monkey
pox are I forget his name he had the
Greek name
the guy who took pictures of himself
wearing leather harnesses in the shape
of a pentagram on top of the pentagram
tattoo on his chest
the guy was dressed up
exactly the same way as the people at
Satan Khan remember Sam Brenton who got
booted because he stole too many dresses
and pieces of jewelry out of women's
luggage at the airport
do you remember the kind of imagery that
that guy would photograph himself in
he would take part in public profiles he
was so proud of this images of him
leading
men around by the collar as the men were
wearing all sorts of weird leather
occult looking
50 Shades of Gray kind of satanic Vibe
clothing
exactly the same kind of clothing you
would see at Satan Khan
what's the difference
well the difference is
at one of them you can write it off as a
group of freaks at the other one
it's the liberal establishment that
controls the political order of the
country principalities and Powers
spiritual wickedness in high places
speaking of false religion
I've long suspected as you have long
suspected that the global warming
climate change movement is not really
about protecting the natural environment
that actually the movement is just about
totally restructuring our political
economy and the way that we view
ourselves and our relationship to the
world in our relationship to the state
60 minutes
I think probably accidentally seemed to
prove that and they seem to prove that
on the issue of carbon captures there's
technology that can go up into the
atmosphere and just take the carbon out
of the atmosphere the fear is that
there's too much carbon into the
atmosphere that's why when you buy an
airplane ticket they offer you the
opportunity to pay more money and offset
your carbon somehow what do they do I
don't know they say they plant a tree or
something but what does it really mean
well we're going to figure out a way to
reduce the amount of carbon relative to
the atmosphere okay well now we have
technology to do that so if we've got
the technology to just go up and take
that carbon down
then why do we need to drive less and
get rid of our gas stoves and get rid of
our cars and stop moving and stop
building and we don't have to do any of
that because the technology will fix it
for us the climate change movement says
not so fast you fear that people will
think oh well we can now clean the air
we can just take the CO2 out of the air
so we can carry on with business as
usual all the time yeah but that's not
how it works we must stop the emissions
and wean ourselves off of fossil fuels
that's what we need to do right now on
top of that we also must take down the
carbon that we've already put up in the
atmosphere only then will we reach our
climate goals
so
carbon capture can never be an excuse
for continuing business as usual
but it's that business as usual that
critics are warning against as direct
air capture expands to the U.S that's
because here oil companies are one of
the Technology's biggest boosters they
have been capturing CO2 to inject into
oil wells for decades not to bury it but
to flush out more oil
why
can't we continue business as usual
why do we have to stop all the emissions
why does carbon capture technology
which solves the problem that this guy
is supposedly so worried about why does
that solution
terrify this man and keep him up at
night
because
it is not the case that we can't
continue business as usual because of
the dire threat of the sun monster and
climate change
we have to fear the sun monster and
climate change so that we don't continue
business as usual
totally
backwards
this is the same reason that the libs
oppose nuclear energy nuclear energy
which is relatively safe
extremely efficient
and relatively very very clean
why would they oppose that
well because then we get to just keep up
business as usual
and what the libs fear is not
carbon what the libsphere is not the
melting of the ice caps and the rising
of the sea levels that's going to happen
any day now folks and the the
catastrophic end of the world in 12
years that's not what they fear but they
fear is allowing Society to continue in
a relatively normal way that's what
keeps them up at night
no we can't have carbon no the carbon
capture that's not an excuse to stop to
continue emitting carbon
why not because I said so damn it okay
well that's not a good that's not a good
explanation
at all
not a good explanation in the least
speaking of that
party establishment got to get to a guy
he is an
NBC senior reporter is very very upset
this is a guy who went after me pretty
aggressively after my CPAC speech when
the liberal press were lying about what
I said and twisting my words because
they knew that what I said was obviously
true they knew that it was resonating
with a lot of people and so in order to
attack me and to call the violent mob
out against me they had to lie about
what I said and libel me and then a
little late they got calls from their
lawyers I think and realized they had to
change the words because even under the
very high standard reliable in the
United States today I think they
realized ooh yikes we could be in some
legal trouble here so they changed it
but the story was already out there so
one of these guys was Ben Collins over
at NBC he's a senior reporter at NBC
and Ben Collins is very upset
because in Florida now parents through
their elected representatives have
decided that they don't want their kids
being exposed to gay porn in an
elementary school
and that that's very
upsetting to Ben Collins so Ben Collins
tweets out he says they are literally
stripping shelves bear of books at
public schools in Florida
and we're still getting absolutely brain
dead takes like this one by editorial
pages of newspapers in 2023. grow up and
talk to your actual reporters about
what's really going on you're saying
this in response to a Washington Post
piece about how universities are pushing
back on censorious students first of all
the word censorious is often misused in
our culture censorious means to be
sharply critical of something
doesn't mean just to to censor something
or stifle speech it's a minor point I
digress
Ben Collins is very upset they're
literally stripping shelves bear well
what books are they taking off the
shelves what was the point of this law
they're taking books off the shelves
that that teach false things
about
history sex race reality all that stuff
that teach false things that would harm
students education
and mostly what this is about is taking
books off the shelves that are
pornographic and obscene and
specifically and especially gay porn
like genderqueer by Maya kababi which
you can find throughout
public schools in the United States and
which constitutes very obscene very gay
porn
parents said we don't want our
eight-year-olds being exposed to this
and Ben Khan says this is so this is so
terrible
why why do these people who are not just
Fringe lunatics but well even if they
are kind of fringy lunatics they have
positions of prominence within the
liberal establishment they're senior
reporters in NBC why are they so
hell-bent on exposing your kids your
little tiny kids to gay porn in the
public schools
what's that about that's kind of weird
wouldn't you say
and what what they respond to this with
is they'll say it's not just about this
book
genderqueer most of them feign ignorance
about the genderqueer book say it's not
look at the shelves are bare in some
places to which I say man what the hell
was on those shelves
if you have to go in if there's a law in
Florida that says no more gay porn in
the elementary schools and then all of a
sudden there are bare shelves in your
Elementary School library you got to ask
yourself man what on Earth
was in this Library
before the law was passed thank goodness
the governor and the state legislators
and the parents who impelled them to do
so had the wisdom
to help the kids here
what kind of an education are they
getting now speaking of what kids are
being exposed to
Mr Davies has a new children's trailer
for me to watch
can't wait I'm sure it'll be delightful
the rest of the show continues now you
don't want to miss it
become a member use code Noel scanner
wlas at check out for two months free on
all annual plans
[Music]